weg aus kiew weg aus der hauptstadt
diese bilder hat vor wenigen minuten
unser bild reporter peter hell am
bahnhof von kiew gefilmt tausende
zehntausende die eilig die stadt
verlassen wollen aus angst vor dem was
kommen könnte in den nächsten stunden
denn das russische militär hat
angekündigt dass es einen korridor geben
werde ich ja das soll ein flucht
korridor sein für all die menschen in
der hauptstadt und die botschaft hinter
dieser meldung ist klar beeindruckende
bilder dort von dieser massenflucht die
botschaft dahinter eure zeit läuft ab
ein counter und soll das sein verlasst
jetzt hier bevor es zu spät ist und
deswegen sind dass diese bilder von
tausenden die kirche verlassen wollen
wichtige bilder dieses tages dieses
fünfter kriegstage also direkt zu unser
bild reporter peter hell der dieser
aufnahmen vor wenigen minuten gemacht
hat dort in kiew peter beschreibe uns
einmal was hast du erlebt von dieser
offenbaren massenflucht raus aus kiew
na ja man muss es leider sagen hier
herrscht die blanke angst die leute wenn
wir hinten nicht schauen versuchen jetzt
vom bahnsteig zu bahnsteig zu kommen sie
sind total nervös sind hektisch sie
rennen hier wir sehen die dame sie
rennen hier alle weg sie wollen jetzt so
schnell wie möglich einen zug bekommen
einer der vielleicht in richtung westen
geht wir waren auf den bahnsteigen es
gibt überhaupt keine tickets mehr und
die ankündigung dass es einen korridor
gibt das war heiss war für die
zivilisten hier etwas gutes aber für die
stadt ist das eine katastrophe das heißt
russland ist bereit hier kiew vermutlich
sturmreif zu schießen und sagt im
prinzip jetzt alle zivilisten raus und
was danach kommt lösen wir militärisch
ich will mal ganz kurz eine familie
vorstellen das ist natalie die mutter
die kommen aus dem netz mit ihren beiden
kindern und arbeitet natalie kenly xp me
what
is
it that
[Musik]
way
lebron
james ramsay 42 wie
diesen wo wir jetzt
wohl
etwas
was juve place to hide wenn der theke
vor ort ist in uk
mikel sanchez mal kings of mine lebowa
spiels
weiter patients for life dies ist mein
gott ist groß von michael center
zusammen
das short time right now to leave me
here dass schelling hier und
hier
[Musik]
also wir hören hier die schicksale die
hier zu tausenden auf dem bahnhof jetzt
ein treffen und versuchen zu flüchten
ich möchte einmal ganz kurz zeigen wir
gehen mal rein und gucken mal wir sind
gerade hier rausgeflogen weil die dürfen
eigentlich gar nicht trainiert was hier
von chaos herrscht das sind leute die
werden jetzt hier raus geschmissen die
müssen auf einen anderen bahnsteig gehen
weil da hinten ist es komplett überfüllt
wir gehen jetzt noch mal weiter
[Musik]
sie begleiten gerade live unserem bild
reporter peter hell durch den bahnhof
dort in kiew eine massenflucht erleben
wir mit ihm mit dir peter wir können
hier mal reinschalten nochmal
wir sehen da hinten die treppe wir
können jetzt nicht rein aber wir sehen
die treppe wie viele tausende menschen
hier versuchen jetzt fluchtartig die
stadt zu verlassen die bahnsteige sind
komplett überfüllt und jetzt gehen wir
noch mal hier bitte darüber auf die
seite hier die leute sind alle mit dem
nötigsten mit ihrem hab und gut mit
kindern auf der flucht
hier auch eine familie mit ihrem mit
ihren mit ihren kindern hier rechts
das problem bei den meisten hier ist
dass sie keine fahrkarten haben und dass
sie überhaupt keine möglichkeit haben
gerade zu werden also keiner weiß wo er
jetzt hin zu gehen hat ich habe gerade
auch mit vielen leuten gesprochen die
wissen gar nicht wo sie hin sollen das
heißt sie versuchen jetzt einfach nur
mal wegzurennen wir reden jetzt mal
hinterher und versucht herauszufinden
nach welchen möglichkeiten die menschen
überhaupt suchen auf die schienen oder
auf die bahnsteige zu kommen um
überhaupt mit einem zug wegzurennen
also das sind schon chaotische 10 wenn
man sich das hier anschaut
man kann sich nur vorstellen mit welchen
ängsten diese menschen hier
in der stadt geblieben sind sie haben
jetzt tagelang das bombardement mit
bekommen mussten nachts in den kellern
und in den bogen kann schlafen und
nutzen natürlich jetzt jede chance jede
sekunde um aus kiew herauszukommen denn
das was hier vermutlich droht in den
nächsten tagen
das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so lustig
sein wir kennen bilder aus korsen levy
kennen die bilder aus charkiw wo eben
auch zivile ziele bombardiert wurden
und das ist
der dino arici viel zeit haben die
menschen wie lange ist dieser korridor
geöffnet die lange wenn sie sich
überhaupt noch auf die flucht begeben
entschuldigung das weiß hier keiner es
gibt überhaupt keine information
es ist einfach so rette sich wer kann
die menschen haben gesagt bekommt geht
in die züge sucht euch bahngleise aus
und versucht so weit es geht in den west
korridor zu gehen um dann eventuell nach
polen moldawien oder eben nach
rumänien zu gehen
ich versuche jetzt mal einen kleinen
überblick zu erlangen ich hab es scheint
so zu sein dass
wir bleiben in den in denen sich schon
zu zeigen wir müssen das noch einmal
ganz kurz einordnen peter was hier
gerade passiert wir leben eine
massenflucht raus aus der hauptstadt
denn der hintergrund ist dass russland
angekündigt hat nur noch ein korridor
geöffnet zu halten für alle die raus
wollen aus der stadt kiel von diese
meldung ist natürlich eine drohung an
all die die in der millionenstadt leben
wenn ihr das nicht nutzt dann könnte es
zu spät sein eine dramatische meldungen
und die folgen dieser meldung sehen sie
hier gerade gefilmt live von unserem
bild reporter peter hell am bahnhof von
vier massenflucht richtung westen
wir haben jetzt hier ein offenes geld da
hat sich gerade rumgesprochen dass es
hier ein zug gibt der richtung westen
geht wir versuchen jetzt mal rein zu
gehen
und das sind im prinzip so die letzten
hoffnungsfunken
hier für die bevölkerung von kiew denn
es gab weder eine information wo man
hinfahren kann noch gab es eine
information bus ticket gibt es wird
jetzt einfach alles irgendwie waggons
jeder kann in die waggons rein
hauptsache man verlässt über den west
korridor und vor allen dingen dann außer
reichweite des bombardements und der
artillerie die stadt und will natürlich
dadurch durch diese evakuierung die
zivilen verluste so gering wie möglich
zu halten was mich ein bisschen wundert
es ist hier überhaupt keine
organisation das heißt wir haben weder
polizisten noch irgendwas gesehen die
leute informieren sich alle für sich
selber und geben sich selber die
information also ist kein organisator
der vielleicht die leute ein bisschen
leidet und führt und es gibt ganz ganz
viele verzweifelte sehen gewesen wo die
leute alle total verzweifelt mit ihren
familien und kindern ihr stand und sagen
wir wissen gar nicht wo sollen wir hin
wir können nicht in irgendeiner stadt
fahren wir haben schon ein
entsprechendes ziel aber auch dass da
wird im moment auch keine rücksicht
genommen wir sehen noch mal die schnelle
bewegung hier von den menschen
hauptsache weg schauen auch mal nach
vorne
das sind szenen jetzt von unserem
reporter peter hill gerade live dort vom
bahnhof in trier wo tausende menschen
diese einzige vielleicht letzte
möglichkeit nutzen um rauszukommen aus
dieser stadt russland hat ein korridor
geöffnet das bedeutet aber eben auch das
ist eure letzte chance macht euch jetzt
auf denn das was da drohen könnte in den
nächsten stunden in den nächsten tagen
wird nichts gutes sein das bedeutet dass
die menschen die wir hier sehen weil ich
das alles hab und gut zusammen gepackt
haben jetzt hier an den gleisen warten
und einfach noch hoffen dass sie einen
dieser züge der rausgeht aus ihrem land
vision können väter
das ist richtig ich versuche auch mal
leute anzusprechen noch mal
überhaupt keine
gesagt
ich weiß nicht wo
die wissen überhaupt nicht was auch noch
aus
da drüben stehen
keine ahnung wir hoffen dass
wir hoffen dass alles gut ausgeht mal
sind
ganz ganz erschütternde antworten und
ganz erschütternde szenen und ich bin
wirklich schon sehr lange auch in diesen
gebieten ich habe noch nie so eine
massenflucht erlebt von menschen und
zwar in so einer kurzen zeit und ich
glaube das ist auch nicht übertrieben
denn die menschen hier die anrainer die
wissen was ihm blühen würde die wissen
was es bedeutet wenn die russen hier
wirklich einmarschieren denn sie sind
seit jahren seit 20 14 kennen sie diese
bedrohungslage und auch diese
aggressivität der sehr ausgesetzt sind
seit 2014 immer wieder auch durch
angriffe und eben auch durch die
rhetorik die kriegsrhetorik und vor
allen dingen jetzt auch die neue
kriegsrhetorik die eben auch richtung
ukraine geht und auf deutsch gesagt was
die russen jetzt gesagt haben
verschwindet hier denn wir werden jetzt
bald euer land besetzen und dann wissen
wir nicht was passiert hier mit den
ganzen menschen und das ist das ergebnis
was wir sehen und das ist eine schande
für europa eigentlich was sich hier
abspielt das ist das ist kaum zu
beschreiben mit worten wir leben hier
zwei flugstunden von berlin entfernt
wenn man sich vorstellen würde das
könnten dieselben szenen die auf dem
alexanderplatz oder am berliner
hauptbahnhof sein dass die menschen raus
geschmissen werden aus ihrem land das
sie raus flüchten müssen aus angst
bombardiert zu werden vor vor
luftangriffen seit mehreren tagen müssen
sie mit ihren familien in den bunkern
ausharren sie haben angst auch wir haben
das erlebt drei vier fünf mal am tag
gehen die sie reden hier nachts wir
müssen runter in den bunker und diese
menschen die h teilweise überhaupt keine
möglichkeit gehabt in schutzräume zu
gehen weil sie einfach irgendwo
außerhalb von kiew gewesen sind in
hochhäusern und auch da sind die raketen
eingeschlagen auch da sind sie nicht
geschützt gewesen es gab tote es gab
dutzende von verletzten ich schau jetzt
mal hier kommt der zug an rechts
das ist dieser sogenannte sonderzug
wurde er hingeht das weiß jetzt auch
kein mensch ich hoffe ihr könnt mich
noch verstehen wir wollen eigentlich
noch mal ein paar bilder einfangen hier
von den menschen und
es kommen immer mehr es kommen immer
mehr ist örtlich mehr auf es sind
zehntausende dort am bahnhof von
tierfutter
es kommen immer mehr wir haben überhaupt
gar keinen überblick mehr wir können
jetzt auch mal nach hinten schwenken
genau wenn du mit der kamera mal hoch
ist der kameramann dominik von als wäre
die wunderbaren aufnahmen oder die
schrecklichen aufnahmen hier für uns
macht
wir sind fassungslos eigentlich und wir
hoffen dass es die meisten menschen hier
schaffen auch in züge zu kommen und wir
hoffen dass dieser korridor den die
russen in anführungsstrichen gestattet
haben das muss man sich ja auch mal
überlegen dieser aktionismus da bestimmt
einen einen ein land
durfte herausgehen aus dem eigenen land
das sie ist eine rhetorik die sucht
ihresgleichen eigentlich und die
verzweifelten menschen die hier sind
haben schon denkst die hoffnung
aufgegeben dass sich das in irgendeiner
form diplomatisch lösen lässt sondern
sie sagen sich im prinzip wir müssen
hier raus so schnell wie möglich unsere
kinder unsere familien in sicherheit
bringen jetzt hat die diplomatie
verloren und jetzt hat auch das reden
keinen sinn mehr denn jetzt geht es
eigentlich nur noch darum seine nackte
haut zu retten um seine familie sich
selber und seine angehörigen so schnell
es geht in sicherheit zu bringen peter
hell vielen herzlichen dank dort am
bahnhof in kiew wo sich auch viele
familien trennen müssen die männer sie
müssen im land bleiben die frauen und
kinder versuchen dort einen dieser züge
zu erwischen und sie wissen nicht wo
dieses zog sie hinführen wird wenn sie
denn eine platz dort bekommen das also
gerade chaotische zustände und tatze
zerbrechende zustände dort auf dem
bahnhof in kiew hinterher vielen dank
wir können ihn noch einmal aktuelle
bilder aus kiew zeigen vom bahnhof dort
eine massenflucht und sein kollege peter
heller hat von dort gerade berichtet
hintergrund ist dass russland
angekündigt hat ein korridor raus aus
der stadt von hier zu schaffen raus aus
der hauptstadt und hintergrund dieser
meldung ist eine drohung sonst könnte es
für euch zu spät sein peter hell noch
einmal schnell an den bahnhof dort
wir sind hier auf einem komplett
überfüllten bahnsteig wir haben gerade
die durchsage gehört wir hören es bitte
gehen sie vom bahnsteig weg der zug ist
voll es gibt kein platz mehr und bitte
gehen sie weg von dem bahnsteig
bisherige mitte weil der zug fährt
gleich losgelaufen die leute auch
teilweise auf den bahnsteigen herum wir
versuchen noch einmal weiter nach vorne
zu kommen es sind chaotische szenen die
sich hier abspielt es ist eine
furchtbare flucht eine panik teilweise
bei den menschen weil sie wissen wenn
sie hier bleiben drohen sie in diesem
schrecklichen belagerungszustand hier in
kiew hängen bleiben zu müssen da sehen
wir vorne
die türen schließen jetzt wird
durchgesagt alle menschen die jetzt hier
stehen möchten bitte sofort zurück gehen
wir gehen mal hier bitte hin
hier eine familie mit den kindern ist
hier geblieben jetzt
nicht mehr rangekommen
[Musik]
ausgenommen kann und hat gesagt wir
sollen dann
hat man uns was machen jetzt erstmal
das sind koffer die vielleicht liegen
gelassen worden sind menschen haben
wahrscheinlich ihr gepäck liegenden ssj
case her
also da sieht man wie furchtbar das ist
die menschen sind einfach rein in die
züge und haben ihr gepäck liegen
gelassen es ist egal sie haben ihr
komplettes hab und gut mitnehmen wollen
liegen gelassen bloß weg hier rein in
den zug denn wer weiß ob überhaupt noch
ein nächster zug heraus fährt es wurde
gerade versprochen ist kommt noch einer
die hoffnung stirbt natürlich nicht
zuletzt das wird ihr gleich noch voller
werden wahrscheinlich noch chaotischer
und dann wird es auch zu dramatischen
szenen kommen wir überhaupt hier
reinkommt wir haben hinten am bahnhof
gesehen es sind noch ganz ganz viele
familien mit ihren kleinen kindern die
versuche hier reinzukommen und was ich
eben auch gerade gesagt habe noch es
gibt überhaupt keine ordnung ist
ich
[Musik]
komme nicht aus
wir gehen noch mal weiter durch
gehen nochmal weiter durch hier an der
seite die menschen stehen hoffnungsvoll
die türen sind geschlossen das heißt sie
müssen jetzt warten bis der nächste zug
kommt die lange es dauert weiß weil ich
wir sehen ja gerade bewaffnete
miliz vor uns laufen versuche das ein
bisschen zu kontrollieren
aber viel ist das auch nicht also noch
mal es gibt hier überhaupt keinen
zivilen guide oder einen ordner der den
leuten so ein bisschen erzählt wo sie
hin zu gehen haben und wie sie sich zu
verhalten haben wir können nur hoffen
dass das in geordnete bahnen weiter geht
und nicht dass hier noch ein ein unfall
passiert oder dass menschen oder kinder
auf die schienen gedrückt werden bei
diesem chaos also die chance dass da was
schlimmes passiert ist relativ groß sie
ist ein koffer wieder gefunden worden
das sind hier die sachen die von der
bahn weggenommen werden
also alleine daran und das finde ich
ganz schrecklich eigentlich allein daran
sieht man die hoffnungslosigkeit und die
verzweiflung und die angst der menschen
dass sie ihre kompletten sachen hier
liegen lassen und sagen das ist uns
wurscht was wir da drin haben geld
ausweise und und und hauptsache wir
kommen in die züge reihen und vom weg
ein anderer mensch seinen platz in einem
dieser züge finden mit sicherheit auch
ein grund warum viele sich entscheiden
schweres gepäck einfach zurückzulassen
jeder zentimeter das haben wir an deinen
bildern gesehen in diesen zügen wird
genutzt für menschen die einst nur eins
raus raus aus kiew raus aus der stadt wo
es jetzt diesen korridor gibt sehr viel
versprechend klingt weil er öffnet
natürlich den weg in die freiheit
gleichzeitig kündigt er damit auch
unheil an dass jetzt über die hauptstadt
der ukraine kommen könnte